just hours after appearing only on CBS
this morning singer are Kelly's crisis
manager resigned in a statement to CBS
News Darrell Johnson said he is stepping
down for a quote personal reasons and he
did not elaborate Daryl Johnson say
that's right
yesterday on CTM Johnson made headlines
when he said he would not leave his
20-something daughter along with anyone
accused of being a pedophile or Kelly as
charge was sexually abusing women and
girls you have a 20-something year old
daughter would you allow her to be alone
definitely not with our Kelly I wouldn't
leave my daughter with anybody that's
accused of pedophilia that doesn't seem
like a contradiction to you you're
absolutely depending our Kelly but at
the same time saying you wouldn't leave
your own daughter with it I wouldn t my
darling anyone come on say it again
that's used again a pedophile all right
our Kelly is currently being held
without bond after his arrest earlier
this month on federal sex crime charges
in Illinois and New York you could
always you could almost say it was a
case of the crisis manager creating a
crisis I talked to Daryl last night he
said he was not asked to step down but
he's stepping down he says for personal
reason reasons because he believes he
could become a distraction to our
Kelly's case he believes in our Kelly he
believes in this his whole process and
he says at the end of the day the courts
will decide yeah no one asked him to
leave he said no it certainly seemed
like he came to a realization at our
table what was being alleged yeah and
all of a sudden it dawned on him yeah
yeah